breaking news the fbi has seized 3.6
billion dollars in stolen
cryptocurrencies from hackers and
rappers i'm coffeezilla this is the 10
million dollar studio welcome back
now two people have been arrested so far
in connection with these stolen funds
elia lichtenstein and heather morgan now
this 3.6 billion dollars comes from a
2016 hack that targeted bitfinex a
cryptocurrency exchange you might
remember them from our tether saga
notably ilya and heather are not accused
of hacking bitfinex itself but rather
laundering the money afterwards they are
both charged with conspiracy to commit
money laundering and conspiracy to
defraud the united states which together
carry a maximum sentence of 25 years in
prison now we're gonna get into all the
specifics of how these two were able to
do this but it's worth noting that i
don't think these charges are near
enough the girl especially heather
morgan should be incarcerated for at
least another 25 years purely on the
basis of being unbearably cringe so look
here's the thing as i said the fbi
seized it from hackers and rappers yes
this lady heather is a rapper she calls
herself the crocodile of wall street
she's obsessed with alligators and um
she raps
terribly i mean she's a rapper sort of
in the same way that american idol
singers are singers
[Music]
now i know what you're thinking we might
have just uncovered the real crime here
and it's true but honestly here or out
she's she's a lot of things she's not
just a rapper
look i'll let her tell it i'm many
things a rapper an economist a
journalist a writer a ceo and a dirty
dirty dirty dirty horrible rapper that's
right ladies and gentlemen this is who
stole all this money
billions billions of dollars laundered
it this is who it is it's unbelievable
and you know what the only honest thing
might be that she's a writer see i
looked into this and it turns out that
that's actually true
uh heather morgan turns out to be a
forbes contributor they just let anyone
in these days and one of her articles
was this experts share tips to protect
your business from cyber criminals you
know what i think she actually might
know what she's talking about you see
guys you just have to learn to protect
your business from criminals by
criminals another thing that she raps
about uh as as a professional rapper
that she is
is um the the cove the cove the social
distancing guys she's she's out there
helping people out um scaring them away
from her i think
do your part social distance do your
part social distance do your part social
distance stay six feet apart you know
what if i saw someone dancing like that
i would social distance from them
permanently and the song who's got
coronavirus
i don't know man
it's so bad that it might be
good
what is what would fantano give it i
feel like fantana would give this a
10. all right so i'm sorry i'm sorry
rapper career we had to discuss that but
listen let's get back to uh the
the case story stephen come on the case
um the fbi broke it down like this with
this chart basically how this worked was
after hacking funds these two laundered
the money through a series of
cryptocurrency accounts including
cryptocurrency exchanges like coinbase
kraken and binance
they would then send that money to a
series of made-up identities now bear in
mind this wasn't that sophisticated
because they kept using new email
addresses but using the same photo so
these two feel like amateurs but at the
same time they were using thousands of
transactions to try to hide these
movements so in some ways they weren't
they knew what they were doing and this
whole case is kind of like that it's
like a little bit sophisticated but then
also extremely amateurish these two
aren't exactly genius criminals if the
rap songs were any indication but this
report also hinted about the fact that
this also might be the work of another
person too according to the affidavit
the information contained quote includes
information provided by private entities
that the us government believes to be
reliable aka
probably a whistleblower maybe a friend
of these two
and it would make sense why they were
motivated to do that because according
to the affidavit bitfinex offered up to
five percent of any property recovered
the total potential reward
exceeds 400 million dollars so it just
might be the case that someone out there
a friend perhaps of the crocodile of
wall street might be crying crocodile
tears when these two go to jail
thinking that maybe they can get some of
that reward money but no matter who it
was i'm just glad these two got caught
and i hope the judge considers an extra
sentence for all the emotional damage
this story inflicted on all of us who
are now being subjected to these two's
work
that's it see ya do your part social
distance do your part social distance do
your part social distance stay six feet
apart